[Music]
to make it big you've got to start small
a rehearsal room into beer a provincial
Russian City eight weeks before the show
[Music]
just 11 years old lead singer Tanya
galkina is one of Russia's youngest rock
singers my best mates are quite a bit
older but if I were to play with kids my
own age we could never achieve this
quality were team tanya has been chasing
her dream of talent show success for two
years
she'd applied for golus Russia's version
of The Voice once before but didn't make
it past the first round since then she's
been rehearsing every day in her
hometown - there the city lies on the
Volga and on the rail line between
Moscow and st. Petersburg Tanya's having
private singing lessons with her voice
teacher
Masha field over Tiger has an unusually
strong will to sing rock you must have
an inner motivation tanya has that and a
natural presence just four weeks to go
till the show
tanya has to go to Moscow to rehearse
with the orchestra for Russian
televisions channel 1 but the ensemble
has little experience with hard rock so
can it work
he's doing we usually play this song
twice as fast
I listen to thought what finally the day
of the show has come and Tania's hoping
that a slower version of the song will
strike the right chord with the jury be
ready to go on at 20 to 11 millions of
viewers all across Russia are waiting to
hear who the jury will send to the final
round
Russia has been in a talent show frenzy
for years now
[Music]
young performers sing their versions of
songs by big stars that last Tanya
Garkinos on with her own interpretation
of Nirvana's grunge anthem smells like
teen spirit
the jury's made up of three famous
Russian singers they sit with their
backs to the contestants judging solely
on what they hear if nobody's turned
their chair around by the songs end the
singers out of the running
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and that's just how he goes Patania
none of the jury members turned around
the 11 year old aspiring lead singer
from Sevilla has to fight not to break
down in tears what can I say she's just
not right for this format or rather
channel ones not yet ready for Tonya's
music they'll be hearing from me no
happy ending Patania
other youngsters are waiting backstage
hundreds while thousands sit at home in
front of their TVs watching
[Music]
you